the House Ethics Committee opened two
new sexual harassment investigations
into Republican congressman Trent Franks
and Blake Farenthold the probes emerged
the same day the Democratic senator Al
Franken said he would step down Franken
faces numerous groping allegations
Congressman Frank's also announced his
resignation yesterday over complaints he
made very unusual requests to female
staff members Nancy Cordes is on Capitol
Hill Nancy good morning good morning
multiple congressional sources tell us
that Frank's had asked his aides whether
they would ever be willing to serve as
pregnancy surrogates he and his wife
were hoping to have a third child
Frank's announced his decision to step
down just hours after the House Ethics
Committee announced it was planning to
investigate I left the statement speak
for itself what does this team in say
Franks offered no details to reporters
but in his lengthy statement he
explained that he and his wife have long
struggled with infertility saying we
experienced three miscarriages he
admitted that his discussion of
surrogacy with two previous female
subordinates may have made each feel
uncomfortable House Speaker Paul Ryan
said he was briefed on credible claims
of misconduct by representative Trent
Franks and he found the allegations to
be serious the announcement came on the
heels of Minnesota senator Al Franken's
decision to step down I will be
resigning as a member of the United
States Senate Franken was defiant until
the end some of the allegations against
me are simply not true
others I remember very differently I
really thought it was an isolated
incident until I found out it wasn't an
isolated incident Tina Dupuy is one of
at least eight women who have accused
Franken of unwanted groping or kissing I
thought that he was deflecting today I
felt like he was blaming the president
he was blaming other people he was
blaming the women who came forward he
was not taking personal responsibility
for what he did it was really a tipping
point I think senator Amy Klobuchar had
urged her fellow Minnesota Democrat to
step down going forward what message
does this send about sexual harassment
sexual misconduct on Capitol Hill I
think we are in a very difficult time
period but in the end we're going to
have better workplaces just yesterday
the House Ethics Committee established a
subcommittee to investigate claims
regarding Texas congressman and
Republican Blake Farenthold in light of
new details about an 84 thousand dollar
settlement he reached with a former
female staffer paid by taxpayers
Farenthold has denied any wrongdoing
Gail all right Thank You Nancy